hey what's up guys mkbhd here so in
contrast to my last video which was
maybe the most anticipated phone of the
year so far
this one's more on the other end of that
spectrum you might not have even known
lg was coming out with a new phone this
early in the year but they are this is
the lg
g8 thin q and again lg for your own sake
i'm just going to call it the lg g8 so
this is your first look at lg's high-end
flagship phone for 2019 and right off
the bat design-wise it's looking pretty
familiar now as far as product design
language goes i hate when there's
changes just for the sake of change like
sometimes you find a good groove you
want to keep that going and build on
something like that if it ain't broke
don't fix it but this to me feels like a
design that probably could have been
updated a bit but lg is sticking to
their guns here so they're keeping the
fingerprint reader on the back instead
of putting it underneath the glass
they're keeping the notch and the full
array of front-facing sensors at the top
and a slightly thicker than average
bezel all the way around i mean it's not
bad but when you compare it to some of
the stuff that's coming out now you see
where i'm coming from then they're
keeping the headphone jack which people
will love and it's backed by that high
quality dac
they're keeping the boombox speakers
that kind of vibrate the phone at high
volumes but that get really loud it's
still ip68 certified it still has the
google assistant button on the left hand
side and it still has dual cameras they
did shrink the camera bump to zero
though so credit to them for achieving
the rare perfectly flat back that is
nice and the phone itself isn't actually
that thick either so it's nice to get
this balanced feel in the hand
and the specs are updated for 2019 as
you'd expect so snapdragon 855 and then
every spec will be six gigs of ram and
128 gigs of storage and there's a 3 500
milliamp hour battery which should be
good enough for this 6.1 inch oled
display but of course really using the
phone will reveal whether that's true or
not but yeah as far as drastic or
noticeable design changes that's not
really what's going on with the lg g8 i
mean i guess i understand the
fingerprint reader on the back keeping
it you know you might not want to go
ultrasonic under the glass with this
first generation maybe you waited out a
little bit put it in the v series phone
later this year i get that but the notch
and the bezel are actually starting to
look kind of dated which i mean again if
you're coming from an older phone you
might not mind that as much but you
gotta look at what you're up against so
what lg's really banking on is there are
two main new features that will
hopefully sell you on an upgrade so you
may notice there's no holes or cutout at
the top of this phone where the earpiece
or speaker usually is that's because
lg's brought some of that fancy
vibrating oled tech down from their tvs
into the phone so it's called crystal
sound oled and so essentially the top
half of the oled display is the
front-facing earpiece now so you get to
put your ear up to it and use it just
like any normal phone call but the
advantage is now it's holeless so it's
better for water resistance the sweet
spot is bigger to hear your phone calls
clearly and because it vibrates if
you're in a loud environment where you
can't really hear it as well you can
literally put it up against your
cheekbone and it will work like bone
conduction this is a samsung phone so
it's not this one but it'll work like a
bone conduction speaker if you put it up
against your face in a loud environment
so you can hear it better
that's pretty cool now it's not loud
enough to be the second half of a
front-facing stereo speaker pair it's
more just for phone calls but how sick
would it be if the tech got good enough
to actually make that happen for it to
be a really full speaker how dope would
a totally bezel-less full-screen phone
be that still has stereo front-facing
speakers because the screen vibrates
think about it anyway the second new
feature is all up in these front-facing
sensors in the notch and it uses the ir
blaster and the receiver and the new
time-of-flight z-axis camera to do some
interesting stuff that they're calling
vein id and air motion so vane id is a
biometric unlock
that extracts an image via absorption
characteristics of the hemoglobin in the
blood in your hand
so basically you're unlocking the phone
by waving your hand over it and the
sensors are reading the vein pattern
and the blood in your hand
to make a unique pattern to unlock you
that's pretty silly but that's dope so
hey i tried it out i registered my palm
by floating my hand over the phone for a
couple of seconds and then tried the
unlock and sure enough it worked i'd
like to try this against some other
people's hands and really see like how
secure this is it might not even be as
secure as the 3d facial recognition that
it also has but it's pretty cool
nevertheless to just wave over your
phone and it unlocks for you you get to
avoid that awkward like leaning in over
your phone to unlock it like you have to
do sometimes with face id and then the
other new feature is air motion which is
improved with the ir blaster and all the
same camera stuff to do more things by
waving over your hand there's more
shortcuts and more things you can do
without touching it so to activate it
you have to hold your palm over the
phone at just the right angle and you'll
see this little bar appear and once you
get it just right then you back your
hand up a couple inches
and when you do you'll see an image of
your now motion tracked hand appear on
the screen and you can do actions from
there so from there you can do
customizable app shortcuts to open stuff
you can dismiss or enable phone calls
alarms change volume take screenshots
etc and it's kind of cool when it works
you can be watching a youtube video for
example and do the whole gesture thing
to get it to play and if you get it just
right you can adjust playback or even do
the twisting motion to change the volume
knob like you're just turning this
imaginary volume knob over the phone
it's neat but the key with that though
is it's when it does work perfectly and
from the hour or so that i played around
with the g8 it seemed very finicky like
it was very difficult to get it to work
just right every single time like i kind
of felt like i was always searching for
the sweet spot to get it to recognize my
hand just right like sometimes i was too
low sometimes too high sometimes you
know too close to the phone or too far
away and it would give me feedback on
the screen to fix it but i guess the
longer you use the phone the more you'll
get used to it and conquer the learning
curve and get it in the sweet spot every
time but the fact that it was so finicky
kind of gave it this gimmicky feel like
i didn't really want to go through the
learning curve to get it to work but
endgame i guess in a perfect world if
this works exactly the right way you're
you're cooking or something and you got
stuff on your hands so you want to just
wave over your phone and open up a clock
and set a timer boom just does it just
like that you don't ever have to touch
your phone or get stuff on your hands on
your phone but as of right now it's like
you can open apps
but then what
like you still have to go on the app and
do what you want so it kind of feels
incomplete and it's not even lg's fault
like they built the way to get into
things um but we have voice assistants
now that are kind of doing more already
so just kind of feels a little tough so
as a feature i think that falls in the
gimmick bucket for now it definitely
makes a really cool demo which is
awesome but i think if you think really
far out in the future it could be really
cool if you believe that's where things
are going so yeah that that's basically
the lg g8 uh pricing ford is going to be
similar to the g7 so in line with
flagships somewhere in the neighborhood
of 800 like last year i'll update the
description when there's an official
launch price but yeah my conclusion is
this is a super minor update to this
phone it's like a g7s which is fine that
doesn't mean it shouldn't exist that
just means you know people who like the
g7 will like this uh but it's not gonna
win any people who weren't convinced by
the g7 or the g6 it's very much in the
family but let me know what you guys
think in the comments below if this is
your next either way thanks for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace